Aaron is in San Antonio hi Aaron how are
you fine thanks 8 how are you better
than I deserve what's up well my husband
and I have been following you for
probably about seven years been working
on your baby steps we have five children
my husband makes about $100,000 a year
before any bonuses what kind of bonuses
it's around two grand once a quarter so
it's not like okay so about another
$8,000 a year give or take yeah all
right yeah we say 15% toward retirement
that we have no debt except for our
house good where we're now saving for
college good you got five plants we have
I built in there what age the oldest is
ten and the youngest is 20 months gotcha
okay cool so my question for you is
anytime we come to a financial decision
it's well what would they do
so we're kind of divided I would like to
take our family on a cruise we don't go
on vacations except to go back home to
Utah and visit family once a year that's
the only vacation we've ever really done
and we just moved to San Antonio San
Antonio where we now have the coast in
driving distance so I want to go on a
cruise and he it's going to cost us
about $2,000 take all of us on a cruise
$2,000
yeah cruise you going on that's cheap
well it's kind of a last one of those
last minutes if you have to be flexible
on your date and take the whole family
all five kids all five kids Wow
okay all right actually I lied at 2200
I'm sorry well it's close enough I mean
wow that's that's very inexpensive okay
yeah and you have this money in addition
to your emergency fund yeah okay so you
have the cash and so what
so let me ask you this it's interesting
you say what would Dave do I don't think
it really matters what would Dave do
because when you're asking yourself what
would Dave do what you're really asking
yourself is I hope what you mean is
what's the smart thing the wise thing
for our family to do yes that's really
what you're asking isn't it I guess so
yeah yeah so what is the wise thing for
your family to do you're out of debt
you're putting 15% of your income into
retirement you're starting to save
towards kids college you haven't you
don't take a lot of vacations except to
go back home to family you make 108
thousand dollars a year is that the
picture you gave me yes there's
something I'm missing well my husband is
a tightwad
he's a penny pincher so he doesn't want
he's like oh that's a lot of money I
doesn't want to spend it and I do okay
if you had told me 20,000 I would have
flinched okay but at 2,000 and it's not
something you do it's not a regular
pattern of yours you have the cash you
can't afford it Dave and Sharon Ramsey
would take that cruise okay
that's what we would do now because let
me tell you that there's you have to
enjoy money save and invest money and be
generous with money if you're going to
win with money you have to do all three
you can't just save because eventually
the money become takes on this the this
toxic part of your you know your the
only emotion you've got towards money
then is toxicity and your kids grow up
hating the idea of a budget or hating
the idea of investing because you know
all you do is live like no one else you
never live like no one else so that you
can live and give like no one else part
of the reason we do this not the only
reason we do it but part of the reason
we get control of our money and build
some wealth which you have done is so
that you could enjoy it it's a valid
reason and that has to be done within
reasonable ratios within the numbers
you've given me those ratios are more
than reasonable again if you had told me
20,000 I would have flinched I would
have blinked
I might said no that's that's you know
that's pretty heavy
I would I would have stammered it on
that one
but 2,000 bucks I'm out of here okay you
see how I arrived at that conclusion
yeah yeah I understand okay and by the
way your husband I mean we can we can
pick on him and have fun with him being
a tightwad
but it's partially his personal
responsibility in this area that has
gotten you guys to where you are I'm
grateful he's gone yeah yeah you got you
got a good one there so all we got to do
is just learn to enjoy it also but not
to the point that we destroy our giving
or we destroy our investing and we're
not doing that with $2,000 out of 108
thousand dollar income so that that's
how I analyzed that and you guys can
look at it however you would like but
that's a good good question thanks for
the call
you